toute la maison je sois plus de
l'assurance la coop sache en bourse les
20 restants pensent pas du genre à faire
ça à ta femme
et puis tu es pas du genre paye
assurances n'ont pu alors oublie
j'ai presque plus de femmes
bien fait là ce soir tu n'es pas sauf
qu'avec la poudre
la foire
mais ce soir
pourquoi savourer
pourquoi savoir tout le temps
et j'ose dire que
organiser un concours international de
pétanque le 21 juin à béziers j'invite
tous les joueurs amateurs professionnels
dans nos villes dans nos campagnes
inscrivez-vous vous n'avez rien à perdre
et pour le gagnant je vous propose cinq
cent mille euros
quand même certains c'est pour nous un
moment soit et vous attend fini les
combines le voilà deux gros coups il
faut se présenter
titouan par abc l'abruti la toile à vis
de qui je parle a plus envie de devenir
un champion
demain tu t'inscris après ce lâche plus
mais tentera dé mais je te préviens tu
vas souffrir on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps
on est en train de rêver l'aja qui
rêvait moines septembre et des mois à
l'image façon magnifique
la thaïlande est revenu au score dans
cette finale mais la france compte un
atout majeur son tireur son canonnier
mokhtar duality moment il se place dans
le rond central
il vise la boule avec son bras site
lacarrau la france et champion du monde
la foule acclame il va pour tirer
il incombera
moi
la boule s'envole elle s'envole par ko
ko à la fois aussi champion du monde